Carter has been monitoring the situation
at the southern border all month and she
joins us now with more Sarah there's a
lot to be alarmed by but to me these
24,000 Chinese migrants Gordon Shang
said one of the possibilities that came
to his mind when he heard about this was
either Ministry of State security agents
or Chinese military coming into our
country your
thoughts oh I can absolutely agree with
Gordon Chang on that he's also a friend
of mine and somebody who I highly
respect uh and he has traveled
throughout the region he and I have been
to the Far East together um where he has
given a number of speeches we've been
watching and monitoring China as well as
other adversaries such as Venezuela and
Iran Russia they are all taking
advantage of this crisis at our Southern
border Kaye think about this the United
Nations is now stating um and this is
the second time that they have done this
that the land Crossing between the
United States States and Mexico is the
most dangerous land Crossing in the
world the most dangerous land Crossing
in the world we have people coming into
our country from all over the world
they're not getting background checks
Immigration and Customs Enforcement are
basically throwing their hands up in the
air the Biden Administration is allowing
them to come in so they're aiding and
abetting these traffickers but it's not
just about the cartels right we already
know this we know that the cartels are
being used as proxies by the Chinese
government to move in F F we've lost
over
112,000 Americans many of them young to
fentanyl poisoning and Fentanyl overdose
we are looking at Chinese migrants The
Surge is absolutely incredible we can't
even get background checks on them
because the Chinese government is not
cooperating with us because they don't
want to cooperate with us this is part
of breaking the back of America and what
Gordon Chang is saying is important and
I'll wrap up on Gordon Shan's thoughts
on this look when people come into this
country and they disappear appear into
the fabric of America they can be
anybody they can be found spying on our
installations our government
installations they could be scuba diving
um you know in our ports of entry and
collecting data on us they could be
delivering food to buildings acting as
couriers but really placing uh you know
uh technology and equipment that they
could use to spy on us our agencies are
well aware of this the problem is they
just aren't stopping it and nobody knows
how far this is going to go before we
actually
break and Sarah I have just a moment
here but CNN's reporting that this
number of migrants south of our border
north of Mexico could be as much as
15,000 migrants on top of these record
numbers yeah absolutely I just spoke
with a source who was saying the same to
me and that they are expecting that this
Caravan this new Caravan to swell now
remember uh Maduro in Venezuela is very
active at looking at what he can do and
this is not just me saying this we have
us intelligence uh uh officers
investigating this right now in Central
America looking at how Maduro is
handling this moving people we don't
even know if some of these people are
coming out of Prisons we don't
understand how they're just uh forming
into these large Caravans and then
moving and collecting people on the way
and this isn't just about our own
National security for Democrats out
there that have um concerns about the
humanitarian crisis and Republicans
there are children in these Caravans
that are losing their lives on the way
to our country they will never make it
they're being taken by these cartels and
these human traffickers they are being
sold into the most heinous and
nefarious I don't even want to say
pedophilia Rings that's the only way to
describe it and even when they come to
the United States many of them disappear
so Kaylee like I say with Tom Homan all
the time and he says this every single
time he's on Sean's show what is so good
about leaving this border wide open why
is our government doing this and why is
nobody stopping
it yeah why is the question Sarah Carter
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else